so you've agreed today to do a little
acoustic thing of course one of your
classic songs black hole Sun we want a
room alone when you wrote that song I
was in a car driving home I get 4 a.m.
when I wrote that song in your head like
in other words yeah you're driving along
and the tune comes T in your head yeah
the whole thing and even even the solo
was all in there and then I raced you
know I just tried to keep it revolving
so I wouldn't forget went inside kind of
whistled it into a tape recorder which I
never listened to back to but I just in
case I forgot it and then the next day I
kind of wrote out the lyrics and but I
had the lyrical idea and everything and
it all meant something to you and you
heard it in you hear it in your head
almost like you listening to the radio
exactly
[Music]
in my in this ball in disguise is no no
that's the face last name there is only
- Grady balling me some especially
through black the sky still
come on
[Music]
do you scream again
black hole some to come wash away the
rain black hole Sun won't you
[Music]
still don't pull them down still along
with two friends time song for honest
and sometimes but to know the state in
my shoes walking sleep in my youth I
pray to keep heaven sent
[Music]
sings like you and more black hole song
she come wash away rain like a song
why don't you call
[Music]
black holes
won't you come won't you rain black hole
Sun won't you come won't you
[Music]
hang my hair drown my feet till you all
just disappear
black hole Sun won't you come wash away
the rain black hole Sun won't you come
[Music]
black hole Sun won't you come who walks
away the rain black hole Sun won't you
come won't you come won't you
[Music]
[Applause]
won't you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]